we see them heading to Winterfell and
they're going back is not so secret
lovers hi everyone its charlie HBO just
dropped a new game of Thrones Season
eight iron throne promo with a couple
big Easter eggs in it that kind of gives
us an idea for some of the payoffs and
reversals later in the season mostly to
do with Jon Snow Daenerys Targaryen
story as it applies to endgame in their
quest for the throne because HBO's
selling season 8 all the promos that
they've been releasing for the throne
they even have a special promotion right
now about finding the actual throne what
were you willing to do to win the throne
so we'll break all the Easter eggs down
there paying off a lot of scenes that
they set up on earlier seasons of the
show like the idea that Jon Snow is
going to learn the truth about his
heritage paying off a scene from season
1 episode 2 where Ned Stark and him part
ways as he goes to the wall and they go
down to King's Landing and Ned Stark
tells him the next time we're together
we'll talk about your mother what have
you seen in the season 8 trailer you've
seen a lot of Jon Snow in the crypts of
Winterfell at all the statues Lyanna
stark statue his mother that he may or
may not know about during this moment
when he's with Daenerys and in front of
Ned Stark statue thinking about his
father what a coincidence then that if
he were to learn the truth while he's
standing near Ned Stark statue in the
crypts and Sam bull walks up and tells
him everything if you're brand new to my
channel I'll be doing Easter egg videos
and episode videos just like this
history videos for Game of Thrones all
season long and for the Game of Thrones
prequel series which is supposed to
premiere next year so be sure to
subscribe to get all those we also do
weekly giveaways that I'll explain at
the end of the video the Iron Throne
promo that they just released is just
laden with a lot of foreshadowing about
endgame for the Iron Throne though so if
you look at this it's actually drogon
XY's transposed with the Iron Throne
itself they cut up a large portion of it
just because it's meant to be poster
sized but you see as you slowly move
down the actual Iron Throne it sort of
blends into dro Khan's spikes so that by
the time you get down to his eyes it's
mostly dragon with a little bit of Iron
Throne mixed in the Easter eggs and the
foreshadowing built into this or mostly
that Daenerys is focused on the Iron
Throne but also that she will eventually
achieve it and also pay off a couple of
keys
scenes from previous seasons on the show
also a really big reversal so there are
three key foundations to every really
great story there's a set up a payoff in
a reversal the foreshadowing is Daenerys
in the house of the undying during
season 2 episode 10 she has visions of
several different things primarily the
iron throne room the wall at Castle
black as the gate is coming up which was
foreshadowing the coming of the night
King and also which they paid off with
her going north of the wall she sees a
vision of her baby with Khal Drogo as he
would have been had he lived which also
foreshadow some other things that are
happening during Game of Thrones season
8 which I'll talk about during other
videos but as you see her enter the iron
throne room winter has come she slowly
approaches the iron throne it looks like
it's been destroyed in battle and she's
achieved the thing that she's wanted
this whole time but remember this is way
back during season two so she had just
started her quest for the iron throne so
at the time this meant a lot more than
her just winning the throne it was all
about her coming back home because she'd
been living in exile her entire life so
the iron throne represented a lot of
different things for her not just
rulership of Westeros
Senate payoff reversal the payoff for
that setup then is than if she actually
walks into the iron throne room during
season eight where she will literally
come in sight of her actual goal winter
has already come to King's Landing so
that part of this prophecy has already
come true the only thing that's left now
is as to what actually destroys the red
keep in King's Landing is it Daenerys in
her battle with Cersei or is that the
knight King in vissarion that come to
King's Landing
Amelia Clarkson something really
interesting about one of the final
scenes that she filmed for Game of
Thrones even though they shoot scenes
out of order so chronologically it's
probably not the final scene of the
series she said that the last scene that
she filmed was just an insert of her
hand reaching out in what happens in
this vision she's reaching out to touch
the Iron Throne during season eight the
payoff for this scene would be her
actually reaching out and physically
touching the Iron Throne while there's a
little bit of snowfall around her but
the really important idea though is that
then there is a reversal setup payoff
reversal so what would the reversal be
if this entire time they've been selling
for the throne everybody wants the Iron
Throne
Daenerys won't stop talking about how
the Iron Throne is hers by right they
actually did that a lot during season
seven she mentioned that several times
in conversation with different people
not only John snow but also tyrion and
varys the Iron Throne is mine by right
the reversal and what's implied by this
poster here is that she's going to use
drogon to melt the Iron Throne because
not only is it a huge reversal on
everything the show has been built on
it's called Game of Thrones is built
into the title of the show the other big
Easter egg they would pay off and her
actually using drogon to burn or melt
the Iron Throne would be for Aegon's
conquest because he used balerion the
black dread to forge the Iron Throne so
to speak the thing about the TV show
that it doesn't quite get right about
the Iron Throne is that it's actually
enormous Aegon made it with a thousand
different swords from all the conquered
kings and peoples that did not bend the
knee to him so like Torrance Stark bent
the knee they actually used that line of
dialogue during season 3 episode 7
forgive me so Davos I never did receive
a formal education but I could have
sworn I read the last King in the North
was Torrance stark who bent the knee to
my ancestor Aegon Targaryen in exchange
for his life and the lives of the
Northmen Torrance talks will fealty to
House Targaryen in perpetuity
I believe your ancestor Torrance stark
bent the knee to my ancestor Aegon the
conquerer there are no stark swords that
were melted down and put into the Iron
Throne but it took Aegon the conquerer
59 days with workers blacksmiths to
hammer all those swords out with help
from balerion the black dread melting
them all down so it took Dragon Fire to
make the Iron Throne somatically it
would make sense the Dragon Fire would
be the thing to unmake the Iron Throne
and it would be by Daenerys choice
because you win the thing that you want
so much but then you recognize how much
of a problem it's been this whole time
think about it this way Daenerys has
been talking about breaking the wheel
ever since the end of season 6 after
she's sort of won over the Dothraki
horde and got all those blood riders I'm
going to break the wheel she wanted to
serve the poor and the rich alike she
doesn't really done a great job of
explaining what that actually means
she's just saying that she wants to be a
much better ruler than those that have
come before her and not at all like her
father that's a Mad King it makes sense
that if we're talking about metaphors
here that the Iron Throne itself is sort
of a visual representation of the wheel
quote-unquote that Daenerys is trying to
break because it is the thing that all
these Great Houses have been worn
over for all this time robert's
rebellion the war of the five kings you
go back even further the Targaryen Civil
Wars the Blackfyre rebellion everyone in
the kingdom throughout history warring
over the actual iron throne itself so
the end of the season they're successful
they defeat the night king they break
the wheel they melt the Iron Throne but
it takes drogon to do that that's why
they probably transposed dragon's eyes
with the iron throne in not vissarion's
because like they have that promo image
of the knight King sitting on the Iron
Throne it looks very ominous very cool
poster but a bit of a misdirect that's
why they have everyone sitting in the
Iron Throne like obviously not all these
different people are going to actually
sit on the Iron Throne so I've been
talking about setup payoffs and
reversals mostly having to do with
Daenerys scenes but also remember that
this will be true for every single
storyline they'll be trying to pay off a
lot of big arcs obviously whether he
wants to or not
Jon Snow is very tied up in the idea of
the iron throne because now that we know
that he was not born a bastard he is
actually a more illegitimate heir than
Daenerys is so however they decide to
make use of it I think we can assume
that they'll be using that for a little
bit of drama obviously John Snow loves
Daenerys they want to be together but
they're torn by this secret that gets
out Jon Snow secretly the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark Daenerys is
his aunt there's all the scenes
foreshadowing that Daenerys is going to
become pregnant in Jon Snow is gonna be
the other half of that it's not so much
a question of them paying these moments
off it's a question of when they're
going to pay them off so I think
obviously the first thing that will be
found out will be Jon Snow's true
heritage then once everybody throws up
in their mouths a little bit thinking
about how they've been together as a
couple this whole time they'll clear the
path later in the season for Daenerys to
potentially find out that she's pregnant
because it would make sense that you pay
one off first so that they're apart but
then that brings them back together
because it's not enough that Jon Snow
just cares about Daenerys and wants to
be with her there has to be a much more
compelling reason for him to set aside
all the discomfort that he feels about
what their real relationship is what his
true heritage is one of the great
foundations of his character especially
early on in the story when you learn
about him is that he hates the idea of
bastards there's a lot of self-loathing
the way the Catelyn treated him growing
up causes him to constantly want to
prove himself he doesn't feel worthy of
the things that he's given that's why he
was so reluctant to become king of the
north he does a lot of things because he
feels like he has to it's his duty
not because he wants to or he's excited
to if you want to take that to its
logical conclusion there are a lot of
people that are wondering if Jon Snow
and Daenerys will get married during
season eight I don't know if they'll be
enough time for that but if you take a
lot of the book Easter eggs an account
it is foreshadowing that eventually that
might become a possibility and there was
a big wedding that happened in Game of
Thrones season 1 episode 1 there are a
lot of Easter eggs that are paying off
from the pilot episode Daenerys got
married but I think it'll take a little
more evidence to convince me that
they're actually gonna pay that off let
me know in the comments though do you
actually think that Daenerys is going to
burn or melt the Iron Throne and do you
think that Jon Snow and Daenerys will
actually get married during season 8
there'll be more Game of Thrones posting
this weekend but leave all your video
requests and big questions in the
comments below
congratulations Jose Alvarez you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my video on
all the Easter eggs about Jon Snow
potentially riding dragons during season
eight and click here for all my Game of
Thrones Season eight trailer Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight